[Aplausos]
[Música]
imagínense
diciembre de 1994 nunca me voy a olvidar
de ese mes porque estábamos con mi
esposa a punto de tener nuestra segunda
hija vivíamos en boston s en ese momento
y claro en la semana 40 o el día de
parto se cumplía el diciembre 31 o el
primero de enero del 95 llega la fecha
de parto pero nuestra segunda hija no
daba ningún signo de nacer no quería
nacer estaba muy cómodo en esa camita de
agua calientita dentro del vientre de su
madre y no nace y yo todavía muy joven
no ha crecido todavía joven pero muy
joven y claro me trepa por las paredes
con la ciudadanos no nace esta niña
entonces claro el doctor nos dijo elin
el ginecólogo esperemos hasta la semana
42 a ver si nace y si no nace hasta la
semana 42 hasta el fin de la semana 42
que hay un viernes en acuerdo como si
fuese ayer entonces habrá que practicar
cesárea
muy bien hay que esperar pasa la semana
41 entrados ya en enero no nace
entramos ya a la semana 42 día jueves
jueves por la noche hora de ir a dormir
mujer mañana hasta entonces y me dice yo
a dormir pues a dormir y sueño no les es
no les miento ni les exagero un ápice
sueño que las caderas se ensanchaban
empezaban las caderas ensancharse una
brutal era un dolor que no se puede
imaginar me agarraba de una cama de las
sábanas gritaba pero estruendosamente y
sentía mi esposa aquí en la cabecera de
la cama que me decía ánimo ernesto puja
puja tú puedes y claro me despierto
sudado y pasó y yo lo primero que hago
es levantar a mi esposa y el ego amor no
te preocupes no hay quien la dirija
mañana a parís ya di a luz a mónica
irene
entonces anécdota absolutamente real
entonces está la luz esta fue la primera
vez que vi a luz no y esa es una frase
que a mí toda la vida me ha parecido muy
bella y también lleva a entender porque
hay francisca pérez en bellas dar a luz
dar luz y si queremos llevarlo más allá
de luz como norte nuestra vida
les presento aquí a mi familia les
advierta con mi familia solamente entra
cuando la pantalla en una pantalla así
de grande cuando la pantalla más
chiquita no entra somos somos demasiados
y claro cuando yo les hablaba de esta
charla a ellos lo primero que me dijeron
es papá muy bien pero ser viese que es
humano que es 10x bueno
innovación 10x es simplemente
crecimiento exponencial crecimiento
exponencial dicho de otra forma es un
crecimiento de un ritmo que aumenta cada
vez más rápidamente y entonces este
pequeñín que está allí dormido que hoy
tiene siete años dijo papas facilísimo
como nuestra familia
y bueno si captó muy bien la idea pero
lo que no le dije fue bueno el
crecimiento exponencial en algunos casos
se puede tener también no ya siete es
suficiente entonces
estoy muy bien
está este mi familia y yo aquí me
presento en este momento más allá de
académico me presento como empresario y
como empresario yo empecé cuando me
gradué de la universidad y teníamos una
empresa familiar mi padre me llamó y me
dijo ernesto por qué no vienes a
trabajar a la empresa familiar fundada
por mi bisabuelo mucho tiempo atrás y
dije bueno esto es lo esto es lo lógico
esto es lo que también es aparentemente
seguro para mí y esto lo que me motiva
entonces fui a la empresa familiar pero
más allá de trabajar la empresa familiar
lo que descubrí esos diez años de
trabajo en la empresa fue el placer de
crear la innovación en la empresa me
dieron licencia para el intra
emprendimiento fui un joven profesional
muy quieto y empecé a presentar un
montón de proyectos en muchos me di
contra la pared me di contra el suelo en
otro en otro estuvo tuve éxito con gente
pero sobre todo aprendí o me di cuenta
de el placer de crear me di cuenta de
esto
avanzó un poco en el tiempo porque la
empresa familiar se vendió a una
multinacional y luego ya dije bueno voy
a emprender por otro lado hoy en día
trabajo para una compañía multinacional
que se dedica a crear empresas
tecnológicas de carácter exponencial
para darlas a luz al mundo y tratar de
mejorar también al mundo con empresas y
con tecnología entonces tengo el placer
de trabajar todos los días con
profesionales de primer nivel de eeuu y
sobre todo de muchas partes de
latinoamérica
entonces me dedico a eso en el día a día
y claro nunca el mundo ha sido un mejor
lugar para emprender ni para innovar que
hoy y nunca ha sido un mejor momento lo
que hemos tenido mejor momento para
innovar y para emprender que hoy ya
ustedes habrán escuchado del foro
económico mundial y de múltiples
organizaciones que estamos viviendo una
cuarta revolución industrial que también
podemos llamarle el mundo 4.0 era
digital es lo mismo pero la palabra
exponencial
lo que se me quedó a mí desde el
principio y lo que ocurre en esta cuarta
revolución industrial es que los cambios
que se producen son exponenciales y
porque son exponenciales porque las
tecnologías de las cuales gozamos hoy
usamos hoy nos beneficiamos hoy cada día
con en las distintas interacciones con
las empresas que nos prestan servicios
el costo de esas tecnologías se viene
también desplomando a ritmo exponencial
entonces esas tecnologías ya están al
alcance de nuestras manos entonces por
eso podemos emprender e innovar como
main como cualquier otra época de la
historia mejor que en cualquier otra
época de la historia y pienso también
que gracias al desplome en el costo de
estas tecnologías está este desplome a
ritmo exponencial estamos empezando a
vivir una época de abundancia y este
puede ser un comentario que los desafío
un poco pero ya estamos dejando de vivir
el mundo de escasez para empezar a vivir
un mundo de abundancia empezarlo
y yo no creo que nos vamos a calcinar
por él por la temperatura del mundo no
creo que nos vamos a quedar sin sin agua
dulce no creo que nos vamos a quedar sin
peces en el océano creo que vamos a
vivir y nos hijos nuestros hijos van a
gozar de un mundo de abundancia con los
nuevos problemas que traigamos con la
tecnología y tengo solamente unos pocos
ejemplos para para simplemente ilustrar
lo que quiere decir con abundancia gente
tenga influyente como bill gates como
mark zuckerberg que no necesitan
introducción están empujando desde la
onu y otras organizaciones más para que
a partir del 2020 todos los seres
humanos del planeta tengamos internet
gratuita imagínense ustedes internet
gratuita esto significa eliminar al
todavía cientos de millones de digamos
de personas que no saben ni leer ni
escribir en el mundo eliminar el
analfabetismo a través de la internet
gratuita poder educar a los ciudadanos
del planeta y de esa manera tener un
planeta menos pobre de aquí en 10 años
en primer lugar segundo ejemplo
solamente para que lo vayan viendo ya
empezamos a limpiar los océanos de
plástico
de esos millones de millones de unidades
de pvc que están tirados en los océanos
con tecnología exponencial ya lo estamos
haciendo ya el ser humano no duda que lo
sea no va a estar limpio de plástico al
año 2050 el ser humano ahorita lo que
dice es cómo hago para no seguir
ensuciando tenemos identificados que son
10 solamente 10 ríos en el planeta
responsable de social del 80 por ciento
de unidades de plástico al océano eso
esta es otra que también es un hecho hay
que simplemente darle tiempo al tiempo
porque la cuarta revolución recién
empieza y por último sin entrar en
detalle usted son más jóvenes que yo la
gran mayoría ustedes piensen que van a
vivir 10 años 20 años probablemente 30
años y con buena salud más de lo que
ustedes están pensando como una
expectativa razonable de vida 80 85 años
son inglés entre 10 y 30 años más
entonces este es el mundo que estamos
viviendo hoy es un mundo exponencial es
un mundo 10 x mundo de cambios
exponenciales pero hay algo me preocupa
que solamente 10x y hay un componente
fundamental que nos hace falta a los
seres humanos para que en este en esta
nueva etapa que estamos entrando en esta
nueva era realmente tampoco se nos salga
de las manos el uso de la tecnología
y aquí
cuando también le hablaba de la charla
entonces a mi familia
me preguntaron y una pregunta un poco
más compleja bueno y esto está bien
piense que ya entendemos lo que dice x
pero y que es 10x humano yo lo pensé
como un título y en ese momento dije
bueno
realmente no sé bien que dice que es
humano pero si tengo que decirlo es dar
a luz todos nosotros en el mundo de hoy
a todas aquellas a todos aquellos dones
oa todas aquellas iniciativas que nos
apasiona tenemos que darlas a luz
entonces aquí me presento ahora ya no
como ser empresario me presento ante
ustedes ahora como ser escritor soy
escritor de poesía es publicado seis
libros de poesía ya terminé de escribir
el séptimo es una es una carrera que
tengo en marcha también desde hace mucho
tiempo escribo con el seudónimo de jota
quintana jk
todo empezó también desde niño común
como un llamado al arte que lo empecé a
canalizar por la música llegue a las
letras por la música y no soy el primer
escritor que llega por la música las
letras
sería muy romántico es decir llegué por
seis y llegué por dante llegué por
cervantes que quizás siempre un nivel
inconsciente conscientemente llegue
porque yo escuchaba de niño a los
beatles a bob dylan al led zeppelin pink
floyd a los rolling stones jimi hendrix
al ajo ya tantas otras bandas que
seguramente todos ustedes conocen y
escuchan y seguramente son fanáticos de
algunas de ellas yo crecí así fanático
de la música y siempre descubriendo que
mi oído siempre más rítmico y melódico
en una época empecé a tocar batería con
disciplina pero cuando nos fuimos a
vivir en el año 2000 españa esa carrera
de baterista no quedó trunca card yo
soñaba tocar en estadios gigantescos
como el baterista los rolling stones no
se pudo dar nunca esa carrera de
baterista y nos fuimos a vivir a españa
y ya dos años en españa yo sentía cierto
sentimiento de desarraigo yo me sentía
verdaderamente ansioso no me sentía en
mi lugar con lo bello que puede ser
barcelona no me sentía en mi lugar y en
un momento dado iba a recoger a una de
mis hijas seguramente a la casa de
alguna de sus amigas iba escuchando
metallica pero como decimos
coloquialmente muy aquilató la madre
metallica tiene ustedes son fans de
metallica
ok muy bien entonces alguno de ustedes
van haber escuchado esta canción esta
canción se llama until it is lips en
español significaría hasta que eso
duerme yo lo venía escuchando a todo
volumen y esa canción habla de algo que
está dentro de tu cuerpo algo que no lo
puedes extirpar algo que está allí algo
que te fastidia algo que te produce
ansiedad que te aprieta el pecho y
solamente te deja unos segundos de paz
cuando se duerme
y dije eso es exactamente lo que yo
estoy sintiendo y en ese momento llegué
a la casa y escribí en el 2002 mi primer
poema que se llama enemigo fiel y está
en el primer libro que publiqué entonces
así es como avanzó mi carrera de
escritor y claro como escritor tú lo que
buscas es poner en la misma frecuencia
tus pensamientos con tus sentimientos y
esa misma frecuencia podemos llamarla el
alma y el alma es algo muy bello es algo
que tiene características de tierra de
aire de fuego de agua de espacio y
también cuando escribes poesía entras en
un estado poético que quiere decir con
un estado poético que siempre ven salir
del estado de la de adrenalina de todos
los días y entrar en un estado más
sensible más profundo más amplio de
conciencia que te permite escribir
poesía y claro yo hablo solamente en el
ámbito literario pero lo extrapoló al
ámbito del arte y estoy seguro que puedo
hablar de un estado artístico del ser
humano y aquí concluyó
diciendo que si bien es cierto está muy
bien el mundo de la empresa el
crecimiento 10x del mundo pero el mundo
del arte es lo que permite al ser humano
permite yo no digo que esté allí pero
nos permite un desarrollo hacia el 10x
ser humano es el ser 10x humano entonces
yo con todo esto me pregunto
que hubiese logrado con dos tardes a la
semana
para poder escribir porque yo creo por
las mañanas yo escribo una hora desde
esa época una hora por las mañanas con
disciplina cuando yo veo desde el
pequeño estudio and escribo yo veo a la
gente que sale a trotar por la mañana y
yo escribo antes que se levanten mis
hijos y la familia y escribo y es el
momento que tengo para escribir pero son
sacrificios porque esos son las que
pudiera estar haciendo también ejercicio
esto que arreglármelas también para
hacer ejercicio no no no no es fácil
pero me las me la he arreglado de alguna
forma pero en todo caso que que fuese
así que las empresas nos dieran dos
tardes a la semana mientras el cuento me
interesa la dramaturgia a mí me interesa
la improvisación
pero no he podido perseguirla
aquí hay algo y es una idea que me
obsesiona y es que pienso que bueno
estos son estos son mis hijos esa
migración no aquí es cuando cuando la
mente se me ensancha mi mente grita y mi
mujer igual está aquí afuera físicamente
siendo vamos en esto no da luz a esta a
esta creación literaria pero lo que
verdaderamente me obsesiona es que nadie
debe posponer ni reprimir su vocación
artística por el mero hecho de ganarse
la vida quien existe únicamente para
ganarse la vida está perdiéndose gran
parte de su vida entonces no podemos si
tenemos un don artístico no podemos con
esa excusa dejarlo en el tintero porque
créanme que nos vamos a arrepentir y
entonces las empresas sí que nos
permiten dos horas a la semana estarían
ayudándonos a ser mejores seres humanos
hacer 10x humanos
las empresas también se beneficiarían
porque el costo para las empresas del
estrés laboral es gigantesco las horas
de sobretiempo disminuyen nuestra
productividad el gasto de salud el gasto
de salud es gigantesco en las compañías
no entonces son miles de millones de
dólares adicionales cada año en que las
empresas deben invertir para ayudarnos a
estar más saludables porque la salud la
el estrés nos lleva en peso y lo que
propongo aquí no es algo utópico hay ya
señales que se pueden lograr hace 20
años o un poco más
suecia da un año sabático a todos
aquellos emprendedores que quieran salir
a emprender guardándole supuesto si
dentro de ese año deciden regresar
pueden volver a su trabajo por otro lado
hoy actualmente pueden escuchar del foro
económico mundial propuestas de que las
semanas tengan cuatro días laborables y
tres de ocio y esto a mí me parece
fantástico yo aplaudo estas iniciativas
por estas iniciativas no necesariamente
no sé
ser es 10x humanos nos hacen más
emprendedores o aumentan el ocio y el
ocio está bien porque el argumento que
dan para el ocio es que consumamos menos
que esté más estemos más tiempo en la
casa y aliviemos el estrés o sea también
tiene un beneficio esa propuesta pero
ser 10x humano significa desarrollar los
dones que tenemos a plenitud sin la
excusa de que tengo que ganarme la vida
entonces hablar también así como
hablamos de empresas exponenciales
hablemos también de arte exponencial que
el arte también sea 10x pues por qué no
elegir ese mundo si empezamos a hablar
un mundo de abundancia en el mundo de la
empresa en el mundo de la tecnología en
el mundo de salvar el planeta porque
también no hablar de un mundo de arte
exponencial porque estoy convencido que
junto con la espiritualidad es el arte
lo que nos va a salvar como especie
humana muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]